foreign
survey of a top of 1 000 of the top 10
percent of U.S earners turns heads this
week because a quarter of respondents
all making 175 000 a year identified as
either very poor or poor or getting by
but things are tight over half of those
surveys dubbed the regular rich said
they worry about money the objectively
wealthy grappling with being
subjectively poor provides quite the
snapshot of this moment in American
history it captures how the increased
cost of everything from Cars to tuition
to groceries makes it harder to Bill
wealth how Rising Generations are
failing to attain their parents
Financial Security and how social media
impacts perception fueling lifestyle
comparisons while making the ultra
wealthy class more visible but even for
the comfortable the goal posts keep
moving there are always the Joneses to
keep up with take the latest trend on
super Yachts for instance don't have
your own submersible on board well
you're practically a peasant
this is gobbledygook this is nonsense
the objective wealthy grappling has
pointed out that the increased cost of
everything is the problem there's no
mention in here of rising credit card
debt there's no mention of what the
average car payment is this is
highlighting we have more and more
people who just aren't willing to be
patient I like to get behind the problem
of the problem of the problem and this
is just highlighting that people are
griping about making 175 000 a year
inflation sucks Dave I got two teenage
boys and yeah my grocery Bill's gone up
to feed those guys they eat a lot of
food but I have margin and if I don't
have margin I can make margin this kind
of stuff makes me so angry daveonomics
inside my household Trump's bidenomics
of course outside my household I like
that I can control what's inside my
walls enough to where if Biden screws up
the economy hint hint then I can still
be okay intent right yeah so now we're
not going to increase or the increase
cost of everything did not make 175 000
people feel poor yes
um
you know what made him poor was one
trillion dollars in credit card debt 1.3
trillion dollars in car debt and 1.7
trillion dollars in student loan debts
all of those with a t terrillion count
that with me boys and girls that's a lot
so yeah they're they're so far in debt
they can't breathe and then yes they're
comparing themselves to uh to the to
people on social media and comparison is
Rachel Cruz says this is great line yep
and her her book love your love your
life not theirs comparison is the thief
of Joy right
and that's what we're talking about it's
exactly right so social media
made these
Rich whiny brats who can't seem to
manage the person in their mirror
comparing themselves on Instagram to
other Rich whiny brats best Sizzle reel
best of picture is uh causing them to
feel like they don't have any money yeah
that's what it is oh yeah so getting by
on 175 000 a year it's a case study
every day on the show you know I help
people get through that the book Babies
touch millionaires where we talk about
all the people that became millionaires
one of the things I had to point out in
that book because we run into it so much
I did an entire chapter on this a
million dollar net worth is not a
billion
no a million is not a billion so let me
help you with this
billionaires have private jets
millionaires do not
billionaires have four houses
millionaires have won
billionaires have seven cars including a
Lamborghini millionaires have a used
pickup
that's correct okay so people think well
when I get to a million dollars I'm
going to be flying private like somebody
on an MTV thing right is MTV even still
open and it's a good question is it
really it's still on there it's still on
the air but I doubt there's much music
on it there's four people on it now it's
kind of gone the way of CMT it just
buried itself yeah okay but anyway they
um yeah so anyway you know when you see
the rich and the glamorous and the
famous what you're seeing are
billionaires not Millionaires and so to
compare yourself as a millionaire which
is wealthy there's only about 14 million
millionaires in the United States that's
all
and so compare yourself with the
billionaire as a millionaire and thereby
declare yourself feeling poor
well it's it's you know of course so
that comparison is the thief of joy
you're right Ken you're exactly right I
mean the opening of this article and and
this is this is we've got to pay
attention to this folks because this
kind of stuff right here that oh I don't
feel like I've got much money when I'm
making 175 000 the problem is is your
feelings you felt you needed a car that
you can't afford you felt you needed to
go to a college that you couldn't afford
you felt a lot of things let me tell you
where this goes Dave and I people told
you you're feeling mattered right it
doesn't matter and and so uh here's
where this goes this is the kind of
garbage these articles are popping up
more and more this is where Universal
income starts to get a hold pay
attention to this stuff just watch for
it folks because when I can't take care
of my bills then I need someone to come
rescue me and you got a bunch of people
going I can't afford my bills bail me
out bail me out bail me out and this
this stuff is Insidious for younger
Generations that's the thing we got to
keep our eyes out for I'm telling you
right now we're seeing it tested several
Mayors and very left-leaning cities are
testing Universal income right now and
it's all because people don't want to
have to deal with their own feelings and
the mess they made for themselves so
they just go take care of it for me let
me tell you watch for it personal
finance is not a feeling it's a math
thing that's correct and so here's a
here's a feeling for you
if you don't have the money
don't buy it
see that's not a Feeling
that's a principle yes maturity and I
but I want it that's a feeling but I'm
going to throw a fit like a spoiled
three-year-old on the cereal aisle
that's a child
it's a child
and I deserve it you don't deserve
anything you haven't earn the money to
pay for it come on yes you know don't
tell me you deserve something you don't
deserve anything shut up call the
wambulance
seriously if you if you deserved it you
could work and save up the money and pay
for it then we could say you deserve it
so people say Dave you need to quit
saying better than I deserve better than
I deserve is not a statement of
contentment that's a spiritual statement
I deserve hell and I'm not going because
of Jesus that's better than I deserve
better than I deserve as a statement of
spiritual Grace it's not that I don't
deserve the success I deserve the
success I've worked my butt off for 40
years at this
and now I'm an overnight success
operating word work
and don't even have to for the last two
decades but did it anyway hello